[Applaudissements]
impardonnable injuste inadmissible ce
sont les sentiments qu'on ressenti les
fans de Céline Dion en découvrant le
classement établi par Rolling Stones le
célèbre magazine musical américain des
200 meilleurs chanteurs de tous les
temps dans lequel ne figurez pas la star
québécoise je les sentais pas venir
selon Rolling Stone il y aurait donc au
moins 200 artistes qui chantent mieux
que la star au 200 millions d'albums
vendus en carrière super une hérésie
pour les fans de Céline Dion dont
l'animatrice canadienne Julie Snyder qui
n'a pas hésité à organiser une
manifestation devant les bureaux du
célèbre magazine à New York
dans l'article qui précède le classement
Rolling Stone a toutefois précisé qu'il
s'agit de la liste des plus grands
chanteurs et non des plus grandes voix
pas sûr que cet argument suffisent à
apaiser la colère des admirateurs de la
chanteuse
la star canadienne pourra néanmoins se
consoler devant cette nouvelle
démonstration d'amour inconditionnel de
la part de ses femmes on a toujours
besoin d'amour bref comprenez-vous que
Céline Dion ne figure pas dans le
classement des 200 meilleurs chanteurs
de tous les temps
[Applaudissements]
alors les amis juste pour vous donner
quelques idées arêtes à Francky dans une
à Whitney Houston Bill et holiday Maria
Carrère Stevie Wonder Beyoncé vice
Presley prince Bob Dylan Freddie Mercury
il y a du nom quand même hein Frank
Sinatra Marvin gay George Michael en 62e
place Rihanna 68e Michael Jackson 86e
bref Céline Dion n'existe pas dans ce
classement mais il a même alors même
Françoise Hardy qui est dedans a dit je
crois normal
j'aurais aimé ivoire figurer Julio
alizés et Barbara Streisand mieux placé
car elle est dedans et déjà en 2008 la
chanteuse canadienne 2008 elle était au
top de sa forme elle avait été évincée
du top 100 donc je sais pas ce qui vous
en parle ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que est-ce qu'en vrai ils ont senti le
coup et elle est finie non je te
rappelle normal
c'est quoi je vais prendre un Pache ok
parce que je pense que Rolling Stones
j'aurais très particulier les gens qui
aiment bien la musique et une certaine
musique etc et qui s'estime qu'elle n'a
pas marqué l'histoire de la musique ça
s'arrête tout simplement ça veut pas
dire que c'est pas une des plus grandes
chanteuses du monde et une des plus
grandes vendeuse du monde elle a juste
pas être pour Rolling Stones pas marqué
l'histoire de la musique qui est pas
loin d'être faux
c'est pas loin d'être faux bah oui parce
que tu parles français à son époque dans
les années 60 etc elle a marqué toute
une génération
avant que vous énervez je peux vous
montrer les fans les fans devant devant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça ça a été sous l'impulsion de Julie
Schneider qui est une grande production
animale
tous ensemble les gens fuient quand les
gens fuient je ne suis plus payé alors
choqué oui complètement choqué on dit
que c'est pas la voix qui compte pour
justifier que Françoise Hardy d'accord
mais alors du coup il y a pas idée de
Piaf ça c'est vrai elle a pas marqué sur
les potes et c'est pas une voix il y a
pas Barbara enfin Barbara est peut-être
moins connu mais Edith Piaf n'est pas
dans le classement il y a Françoise
que ce sondage c'est une veste
fumisterie le truc le moins objectif au
monde c'est comme si Télérama faisait un
sondage des meilleurs animateurs télé et
qui mettaient pas de débrouillard Cyril
Hanouna ou en tout cas
les esprits elle a quand même fait 16
ans complet tous les sorts
alors là c'est la vraie sujet mais
justement comparé succès bien
talent fou il remplit pas autant que
Céline Dion on parle de ces Mathieu
rebondir
et dans le plan de Céline Dion on pense
qu'elle n'est pas dans ce classement à
cause de sa résidence à Las Vegas à
coude à cause de ce choix bah si et à
cause de ce coup on pense ça on pense
qu'elle n'est pas en grande partie à
cause de ce choix et bah parce que ça
souligne un truc très important est-ce
que ce que Rolling Stones a dit
eux-mêmes avant même la publication du
classement c'est à dire qu'on se ça
félicite ça le génie pas une fois
et dernière chose il y a Madonna n'est
pas dans le classement il y en a
beaucoup d'autres qui ne sont pas dans
ce classement donc on est là parce qu'en
ce moment on parle beaucoup de Céline
Dion mais est-ce que Céline Dion est un
génie non mais est-ce que Céline Dion
est un génie une génie c'est ça je suis
désolé mais c'est long
je t'aime tu
pues laisse parler j'ai le mot juste
paraît-il
le journal particulier c'est énorme
petit chameau
Matthieu vous dites il y a le succès les
chiffres et il y a le talent elle a les
deux elle a les deux c'est à dire
qu'elle a fait des records alors des
records de chiffres certes sur les
albums sur les tournées sur le nombre de
fans qu'elle a mais elle a une voix
enfin unique en son genre il y en a pas
beaucoup vendu ok
Rolling Stones c'est des intellos c'est
comme voilà c'est quand on lit les
quatre bien sûr c'est comme les Inrock
c'est comme ce genre de canard etc donc
à un moment donné je pense que Céline
Dion elle est trop populaire c'est la
populace c'est les gens qui l'aiment etc
mais tout le monde l'adore en vrai
Céline Dion
la popularité veulent la carte et ceux
qui ont la carte veulent la popularité
et il y a ceux qui n'ont aucun des deux
c'est moi alors